Bourbon Street New Orleans the bars are
shut the floats are gone
and so are the heaving masses but did
the shutdown come too late in February
city officials pressed ahead with Mardi
Gras two months later the city had the
highest death rate in America we're here
we went through Katrina and the
Franklin's lost four of their family in
just 12 days every other Bay it was one
of the family members four family
members in the same ICU at the same time
it was first my uncle passed then a few
days later and my grandmother passed and
a few days later my dad passed and a few
days later after that other huncle pass
you've dealt with so much loss in such a
short space of time how are you coping
the whole virus is just unbelievable and
what's the hardest for me some people
really think that doesn't exist and it's
not real and we buried four family
members we buried my husband and two of
his brothers in the same funeral three
caskets in a row and it I just want the
world to know that this is real 70
percent of those who have died in
Louisiana are African Americans yet they
represent only 32 percent of the
population local author Maurice Ruffin
believes that is the product of a
perfect storm of inequity this is a
place where we don't have a great health
care system where people don't make a
lot of money and there is some
historical racism that has caused these
factors to make things worse for people
in my community do you think it was
irresponsible at least regrettable that
Mardi Gras took place no I don't think
so I think that 20/20 hindsight is
always easy for people to do but at that
time the India was still playing
basketball people are still having
festivals and conferences all across the
entire country people are going to
church and nobody had any
just any of our leaders that we needed
to avoid gathering at that point in
Baton Rouge some people are still going
to church this is Easter Sunday weeks
after the shutdown began a defiant
posture flouting a ban firing up his
flock
[Laughter]
[Music]
outside is unapologetic what do you say
to those people that accuse you of being
irresponsible putting lives of them I
say to them don't be an hypocrite
anybody that's on that road right now
anybody that's in a retail store such as
Walmart such as a liquor store if you go
to those places but will not come to
church your two faiths the legacy of
Hurricane Katrina haunts this city now
it's being stalked by a virus another
nightmare
for some of America's poorest people
Cordelia Lynch Sky News New Orleans
Louisiana
[Music]